video games New York in Manhattan might
just be the world's best video game
store because as far as I can tell they
have pretty much everything would you
like to see what I thought were the 52
coolest items they have for sale look
this is a special edition pokemon game
queue and this is a special edition
pokemon n64 this is a portable DVD
player with a Game Boy Advance cartridge
slot and this is what it controllers
look like I mean did you even know this
stuff existed this is a Sega CD and this
is a Sega CD mint in the box this is a
Japanese Sega CD and this is a portable
Sega CD in Genesis in one this is Mario
Paint from the United States and this is
Mario Paint from Japan here's some
imported Wii games years before the Xbox
games and here are some imported playing
cars Nintendo actually started as a
playing card company in 1889 they still
make them but only in Japan this is
their joystick selection and in case
those don't work for you they've got
parts for you to make your own custom
joysticks they've got pretty much every
console regardless of popularity
seriously regardless of popularity this
is a Resident Evil for chainsaw
controller repress start by pulling the
cord here's a copy of Resident Evil 4
where the cover was misprinted so that
was supposed to be printed on the side
of the box is actually on the front look
they're not all winners these are games
for the Milton Bradley Microvision the
world's first portable game console
here's a variety Gameboy some of which
have aftermarket modifications like
backlighting and here's some spare parts
if you want to do your own Mountie and
then once you're done here's some games
here Gameboy some games your Game Gear
and some games for your atari lynx this
guy is a glucose monitor that goes into
your Nintendo DS what I have to assume
as the world's worst videogame here's
something cheater solder another
controller for a leg up in Call of Duty
here's a limited edition of one of the
best Dreamcast games it's one of the
rarest Final Fantasy collectables ever
only 2000 were sold and this is
something called a super boy play Super
Nintendo games on its own screen and on
the TV and you can plug controllers into
it and it plays any game not just Barbie
here's some stuff here's some stuff
here's some stuff oh yeah here's some
issues of Nintendo Power here's the last
issue of Nintendo Power here's the
antenna power before was called antenna
power was just a nintendo fun club news
this is what a Neo Geo cartridge look
like this is the wizard edition of
ninokuni this is an 8-bit Nintendo game
from Japan is the factory sealed Harvest
Moon these are Tiger electronic games is
a Pokemon T just - game that never came
out the United States is a game view
with a built-in DVD player there's a
PlayStation 2 development kit and this
is just their printer nothing super
fancy though I think it also makes
copies they have all of your favorite
Mario games including Mario Kart 64
Mario print world and Super Mario and
Friends when I grow up this is a Lara
Croft memory card nothing to say here
let's keep moving keep moving
these are erotic Atari 2600 games let's
keep moving keep moving what else what
else oh
a Playstation signed by Kojima here's a
DSi by Miyamoto here's an ATAR portfolio
which may remember John Connor using to
hack an ATM at the beginning of
Terminator 2 here's a factory sealed
demon watch which with this product and
someone ordered it through the mail and
then for some reason never opened it
basically you gotta get to videogames
New York even moving this fast they have
too much cool stuff for one video